sorry fouchy because your authoritarian
control is going away and it's going
away in real time
that is right a district a middle
district judge of florida tampa division
we've got some info here the court has
declared unlawful the backs the mask
mandate and vacates the masked mandate
remanding it to the cdc for further
proceedings consistent with this order
so just you really need to understand
what just happened here
all it took was one federal judge i
don't know who this federal judge is do
we have a name can i get a name on this
chick
this chicker dude although i'm told
she's a woman
i want a name i'm told she's appointed
by she was appointed by that orange man
scary donald trump but do you see what
happened here one person one judge we
got a lot of federal judges in this
country one federal judge finally said
enough is enough and now we all know
we're in a better situation we all know
we're in a better situation we'll get
her name in just a second here is video
of people taking their masks off on a
plane just as it is announced april 18
dubai administration announced that the
transportation security administration
will no longer enforce the federal
mandate
requiring mass in all u.s airports and
onboard aircraft
[Applause]
finally effective
immediately mass are optional for all
airport employees crew members and
customers inside us airports and onboard
aircraft
it's beautiful and it's also very scary
at the exact same time because here you
have all these people whether it's the
pilot who's an employee whether it's all
the people are on the plane they all did
what they were supposed to do they were
all good citizens and they behaved all
day long and you get a cookie and you're
good meaning you put the mask on you sat
there quietly you didn't talk you never
said hi to a neighbor anymore or any of
those things we destroyed so much of the
fabric of our societies and we did it
because we were all policing ourselves
and there just wasn't enough of us
willing to say enough is enough
so that's the sad part about it but then
the beautiful part is people don't want
to live like this anymore and finally
one person did something and one
person's decision
started freeing the people and dare i
link this back to that moses guy and the
passover story i think there's a little
something there i really do and dare i
link this back to elon musk fighting
twitter and the machine one guy can do
something the judge's name by the way is
judge catherine kimball mizell she is 35
years old she is a young lady she is a
trump appointed judge and she
god bless that woman i want to meet that
woman we're going to the courthouse
tomorrow if anyone wants to meet me at
the tampa bay courthouse tomorrow i'm
just going to be i'm going to show up
i'm going to bring her a coffee or
something
but people have wanted this for a long
time and we all knew it was the right
thing to do and this doesn't preclude
you from wearing a mask on a plane if
you want to you can wear a mask and a
face shield and you can wrap your head
in saran wrap and continue to do all of
those things if you so wish you could do
all of those things okay
but everyone's wanted to get rid of it
this is video from a little while ago
the delta ceo talking about how enough
is enough but he just didn't have the
power i guess he could have put his neck
out there but he just didn't have the
power in his mind to do anything about
it
we think from the pandemic stage to the
endemic stage and we need to learn how
to live with it without being so
restricted
delta airlines ceo at bastion also
pointing to the challenges his own crew
members face are you comfortable with
your passengers dropping masks now
i think our customers are comfortable uh
dropping masks i think our employees are
tired of wearing masks our employees
especially on those on board those
flights are tired of policing mass
it's interesting what he's saying there
because you don't become the delta ceo
without having some power it's like how
do you become the disney ceo you have to
know how to do business you have to have
a pretty good resume so he's asked you
know like do you want to get rid of this
in essence what he's being asked well
everyone else wants to get rid of it
we're trying to figure it out but
imagine if he as a ceo would have just
said hey me and my airline we're not
going to comply and then six months ago
we would have sort of sort of started
this war between airlines and the cdc i
think we could have got out of this
thing much much earlier so again one
person the delta ceo is one guy the
tampa bay federal judge is one gal elon
musk is one guy
this
am i am i making myself clear today i
feel like i'm making myself clear dates
and am i beating this thing into the
ground yeah